At the absolute very beginning of Corona virus,
we would sort of joke, but we weren't really
fully joking that at some point they would
just try to blame Obama for Corona virus.
They being the Trump administration and trumpets.
And of course, we very quickly realized it
wasn't a joke when they started to do it.
Eventually, we started to hear this phrase
from Donald Trump.
The cupboards were left bare by Barack Obama.
Bare of what exactly?
It was not ever totally clear.
It was PPE or ventilators.
There were no tests.
But of course, there was no corona virus or
how could you have a test for it?
And of course, absurdity aside, Donald Trump
did have three years, if indeed he was left
bare cupboards by Barack Obama, which he wasn't.
He was left three years to refill those covered
cupboards before a corona virus hit.
Now, in reality, there were 19000 ventilators
in the national stockpile when Barack Obama
left office, et cetera, et cetera.
But there were three years during which Trump
could have refilled anything that was empty.
They are now going full mask off, as we would
call it.
Here is Tim Murtaugh or Myrt tough?
I'm not exactly, Mark, how Donald Trump's
2020 communications director on CNN just blaming
Obama, just blaming Obama for what's now going
on with coronavirus.
Take a look.
If people were saying don't wear masks because
medical professionals will need them and there
might be a shortage.
It's because the national stockpile had been
depleted.
But that's when the president enlisted.
The role of the private sector and got the
whole of America into the production of masks
and other PPE.
And I would point out ventilators.
You remember at the beginning of this entire
process, we heard an awful lot out of New
York and California and other states about
what they perceived to be a looming shortage
of ventilators.
That shortage never materialized because the
president's strategic level was 19000 ventilators
and a prion.
You know, Tim, Obama left 19000 ventilators
in a plane.
You're lying.
And you don't look like a talking like it's
hot in 17.
It's 20, 20, sir.
It is 20, 20.
It has been almost four years.
Hold on a second.
Let's let's talk about this for a second.
So here it's ventilators and PPE, which Obama
didn't leave us.
Now, of course, Obama did certainly leave
us ventilators and PPE as well.
But there were three years during which Trump
could have boosted those supplies.
But Trump insists no one could have seen this
coming.
So if no one could have seen it coming, how
could you possibly blame Obama?
But if someone could have seen this coming,
even if it's partially Obama's fault, Trump
had three years to get ventilators in PPE
if he saw it coming.
So you can't be on one side of that without
being on the other.
If no one could see it coming, then certainly
it's no more Obama's fault than Donald Trump's.
And if you could have seen it coming then,
even if Obama did something wrong.
Trump also did something wrong by spending
three years not preparing for a problem
that we could have seen coming.
So you've got to be on one side or the other
of that.
They're trying to be on both sides.
So then this guy, Tim Murda, changes tact
and talks instead about testing.
And that just really didn't go well.
Did the testing program that the president
has instituted here in this country, we've
tested almost 26 million Americans.
And the reason and what testing program?
The reason why a testing program the president
has instituted is because this.
Hold on a sec.
Hold on a second.
The reason why a testing program for the Corona
virus didn't exist, a federal program team
was no state because there there was no test.
Listen to this.
There was no test for the corona virus because
prior to this, there was no corona virus.
The test had to be invented first.
So now Tim Tim goes to Trump built testing
because Corona virus is new.
And the test had to be invented.
But that's true in every country, Tim.
And yet most other countries scaled up testing
per capita much faster.
They tried to pretend that this is unique
to the United States.
The origin was China for every country around
the world.
There were no tests for every country around
It's not unique to the United States.
The sudden need for testing for a new virus
was the case in every country.
It was the case in South Korea and Italy and
Taiwan and Greece and everywhere.
We were just one of the slowest.
And this really doesn't get much better before
it can be mass produced and spread around
the country.
And that's what the president has achieved.
Forty six million tests have been conducted
in this country.
We're now testing eight hundred thousand people
a day.
And that is why.
Yes.
And take for two weeks disease that they had
not previously known according to a other.
Hold and other listeners.
If you don't test, get the results back within
five days.
Those tests are pointless.
I mean, this is a testing failure test.
And the.
Hold on a second.
And the present.
No, it is not.
It's actually a tremendous success story.
We're leading the world in testing.
It's so boring that they're still doing this,
leading the world in testing.
We have 330 million people.
The total number of tests is not.
Super relevant.
When you think about per capita.
But I'm actually going to going to say something
that I've started to say on live streams at
this point.
Even looking at per capita is less relevant
because a lot of places don't really need
tests anymore.
Since so few people have the virus.
And what I mean by that is we've now, for
example, caught up to Spain and testing per
capita and we've passed Spain in tests per
capita.
Well, Spain no longer needs to do very much
testing because they've completely flatten
the curve.
So, of course, we're passing other countries
in testing per capita.
Now, in the last few days, Spain has started
to see an uptick in cases.
And that's another issue that we're seeing
in a few European countries, which we're going
to follow.
Let's watch a little bit more here.
Forty six million tests of Americans and 800000
tests a day, not 10 minutes going on.
They're allowed.
Hold on a second.
They're allowing people to now be podcast.
When your five tests at a time, you get a
pretty nice job by Brianna Keilar there.
So if this is one of those situations where
if the facts presented by Tim Murtaugh were
true, Trump had years to replenish empty cupboards
and all of that stuff.
But Tim Murdoch's arguments aren't even real
because the facts are not, as he describes.
And this is what we're essentially down to
now, repeating the same lies over and over
again and hoping that people are accepting
it as the truth so that Donald Trump can get
himself reelected.
That's what that the core of everything.
That's what's at the core of Trump now carrying
his mask with him as a propaganda showpiece
all the time.
This is what's at the core of Trump now saying
it may get worse before it gets better and
taking a new tone and all of this different
than the Portland and Chicago deployments
of troops, all the singular focus at this
point
for this administration and people like Tim
Murdoch is just getting Trump reelected in
November by any means necessary